[Music]
this
is star talk and this is going to be
a covet 19 edition where we're going to
explore
the future of us and
just to be clear since we're talking
about covet 19 we have to sort of
put a date stamp on what's going on so
we are recording this
on october 28th so whatever we say
that's true on october 28th we discover
things after this that could affect
the information that we share with you
so that's my that's my entry disclaimer
on what's going on or rather my entry
claimer
if there's such a thing so my co-host
for this episode
paul mercurial paul hey neil how are you
dude
you're special for this because you
actually had covid yes
yeah you you asked me to get it for the
episode yes thank you you were you are
such a
such a a role player and when we got
here
you're committed you you have to be the
virus
yes exactly be the ball
be the virus you're host of the the paul
mercurio show
which i will never forgive you for just
not being inventive there uh i tried
other things i tried two chairs and a
microphone
the other night i had three ferns
[Laughter]
i tried everything uh i gotta work on
that yeah keep working on it i'll help
you too
i like coming up with new new names of
things okay but today we're talking
about the future of humanity
in the wake of covid and
and also we're going to focus on those
who are
most vulnerable in a societal way which
are the children
right even if children they sort of get
it but it's not too serious and they
bounce back society that is trying to
take
care of them and the society they will
inherit
has been indelibly touched by this virus
and so since neither you nor i other
than that you have become the virus for
this episode
have special expertise we go back to our
man
who's not only an a a specialist
in diseases he's a specialist in
children who get disease and it's irwin
redliner dr erwin
redliner welcome back to star talk
thanks dale so happy to be with you and
paul
yeah let me get your resume just out
there just so people know your
pediatrician
co-founder of the children's health fund
and that's an international thing we
where you just you're helping children
no matter where they are and no matter
their
capacity to afford and your founding
director of columbia
universities national center for disease
for disaster
disaster preparedness and we've had you
on for that reason
before right right so uh
thanks for uh having agreed to do that
you can check our archival episodes for
that
and the show brings you on for all
really depressing stuff
yeah yeah i've been called doctor doom
by a couple of radios oh
man yeah because he's
he's the you know for that other title
he carries that's like
when the asteroid comes and takes out
the grid and the and
the ability to respond with first
responders
so yeah that's a definitely the doom
doomsday
dude doomsday doctor uh and you created
the pandemic
resource and response initiative at
columbia university so what is that and
when did you create that
well we created this back in april when
it was apparent that
things were really going to hell here
with uh
you know especially in new york where we
are and uh
the hospitals are completely overloaded
the fatality rates were through the roof
and uh sort of leading the world in
death and destruction from this uh
covet virus so yeah so we created it
leading the world because of our
uh we just didn't we were ignorant and
and well we um and we didn't listen
we didn't listen we didn't take activism
right
and we actually performed way uh
more inadequately than other peer
countries in fact we just issued a
report last week
that said that if we had done what japan
or south korea or canada australia or
germany had done we could have saved
100 more than 100 000 lives in fact
there were 217 000 fatalities from kovid
a week ago friday which is the day we
issued the report
and at that point and there were 217 000
fatalities
if we had done what uh canada had done
in terms of early on aggressive
interventions we could have saved 130
000 lives neil of that seven so
so so these countries you choose these
countries because they're they
are our sort of uh technological
years social peer group right right okay
so
exactly it's sensible to compare and
economic especially right
right yeah and we should be leading the
world and we have the wherewithal we
have the scientific
power if we had done what south korea
and japan had done we would have had 200
thousand lives saved
uh in other words if we were almost all
of those who died would not have done
almost
all and this is a tragedy of just
enormous proportions and uh it should
not have happened
in the united states but it did and it's
still happening because there's really
not much that's changed in terms of our
policies and leadership uh from the top
so so so this i'm i'm especially
disappointed by this because i'm
old enough i'm older than both of you
guys
i remember no i remember i grew up i
could have adopted you
i changed your diaper i'm just too late
no i i just remember with all the
problems we had you know with vietnam
and all the civil rights we were still
the model of the
world for scientific advances and health
advances exactly
and and i expected you know we would see
these film loops of other countries oh
look at them they don't have an
infrastructure
there was like yeah they would be the
benefit of our
pity right that we would then send money
their way help them
because we are exemplar and now you know
i i feel
like about that it's upside down it's
yeah yeah but the fact is we are now
october 28th at a higher peak
in new covert cases in the united
is that correct st it is correct and the
trajectory
is up there's no there's no suggestion
that it's about to you know peak and
then start coming down again
it's just uh okay so in other words it's
not even leveling it's just
it's not leveling it's aiming high
aiming high
aiming high and uh that's a problem and
um you know what we've been talking for
a long time about you know the winter is
coming
uh to borrow the uh game of thrones yeah
that started there it is coming
and it's uh it's scary it's it's there's
no let up in sight
and there's no way to create a model or
there's no model
that suggests that it is going to slow
down anytime soon and you know there's a
great case study in kansas because the
governor was going to mandate mass and
the republican legislature
then took the power away from the
governor to do that and said that
communities so
all of 120 commute counties 100
said no mandate on mass 20 did and in
july
at that point it went like this in other
words those that mandated mass
leveled off and those 100 counties
didn't
spike and they're continuing the data is
is incontrovertible in fact there's a
compilation of this uh with regard to
um actually a red state blue state
compilation
for what states are leading in new cases
versus others that have leveled off new
york city while our rates have gone up
they're still really low compared with
most other states at this point that's
right
right that is right very proud of my
fellow new yorkers because we're a
crammy
set of people right it's like you know
oh you can fit another 12 people
in that elevator keep them coming you
know it's the only time you're justified
to push an old lady out of it
and i have done it now erwin i want to
talk to you about your book
which is the future of us and we get the
full title what the dreams of children
mean
in 21st century america yeah so what was
driving this book uh neil was my
observation personally you know i'm
taking care of very disadvantaged
children as a pediatrician for
decades and uh there was one particular
situation that uh stuck with me was in
the early 90s
i was seeing a homeless a child whose
family was homeless and this kid
actually was separated from his family
extremely poor he was in a foster home
that we were providing karen
and we're using the mobile pediatric
clinics of the children's health and
long story short
nurse says this is a child named william
a 10 year old in the back examiner with
the mobian and i go in and i'm chatting
with him he's
he's very shy and i asked the question
that
often works which is what do you want to
be when you grow up
and this is a this was a homeless kid
picked up by a foster family
being treated in your free medical care
children's health fund truck exactly
okay
and he was incredibly poor and faced
many adversities in his life but when i
asked him what he wanted to be when he
grew up he said i want to be
a paleontologist i'm saying
really what is a paleontologist he said
well i want to look for dinosaur bones
and whatever i said well how did you
how did you learn about that and he
pulls out an old yellowed
uh article from the new york times about
paleontology and
he kept this in his pocket always and
this was his lifeline
his beacon of hope that someday he would
get out of whatever he's
facing and be able to do that and i
looked at him neil and i was
first of all i was almost weeping and i
didn't i didn't leap i was just
very overwhelmed with sadness by
because i was realizing the chance of
this kid becoming a paleontologist were
essentially nil
and it was very distressing to me and i
happened to be speaking to a friend of
mine um named billy shaw who started a
anti-hunger organization i was telling
him about this story
i was on one of his podcasts and he said
to me well my ten-year-old son this is
billy saying
wants to be a paleontologist and we
bought him you know
a dozen books on the subject we've taken
him to the museums
and we flew him out to actually meet a
very famous paleontologist and i'm
saying
jesus you know this is this is the point
there are some children
who have the support mechanisms from
their family from their parents from
their community
that allow them to pursue their dreams
and there's other children
like william who have no chance and the
fact is that we have millions of
children in america
who face futures that are uncertain at
best
and certainly uh the ability for them to
achieve their dreams
is extremely limited so even if you're
selfish
even if you're selfish where you say i
don't care about these other people i
only care about my people
there is still the loss to the country
for the intellectual capital that is not
being nurtured
that could propel the nation back into a
leadership status
on so many of the frontiers that i grew
up for which if that was true
right and you made this point earlier
neil that um we used to lead the world
in
innovation in science and whatever we
cannot afford
to have so many children or any children
really not fulfilling their potential it
is really
really a terrible um reality that's
facing america's future
and then the kovid pandemic has
exacerbated all that
because the kids that were behind the
eight ball and in trouble
before the pandemic ever appeared are in
worse trouble now in fact
calling them the pandemic generation
of children who have impossible uh
catch-up missions now because you know a
lot of them have had their education
interrupted exactly the last thing we'd
like to see happen
i'll save the save the children did a
survey uh yeah in september
of 25 000 kids and less than one percent
of the poor children interviewed had
access to the internet versus
19 who were non-poor and they missed out
on access to education health care food
and in the early developmental years
yeah once yeah
so this is this is the point paul right
so
we are creating a situation that we're
going to need something on the
akin to a marshall plan uh
to try to recover the potential and make
up the lost uh education just remind me
the marshall plan was
the rebuilding of europe after the
second world war exactly
okay so this this requires like broad
cooperation
and progressive visionary thinking and
investment
and commitment right so this is what we
need
and i think we really need it badly and
so this book the future of us uh which
has been updated
to include uh issues about the pandemic
specifically
it just came out in paperback now right
because it came out before the updated
it looks like this oh you just happen to
have one
isn't that funny
but i'm gonna talk to you but
yeah so this is the point here i think
we're going to need
a lot of work and a lot of commitment
but like you point out you know this is
not just
about a focus on our own children that's
easy
for people like us and we got the
wherewithal we can do it
it happens to be understanding with
empathy
that there are many many children who
don't have what we're able to give our
children
and it's in our interest as well as
theirs right that we are able that we
need to
to help them redress even if you're
feeling selfish
so so you use the term that the children
are the bellwethers of
any society could you just give me a
little more detail about that
yeah so what i mean by that is that if
by the way because we have a comedian
with us paul i've always thought of
comedians
as the bellwether of society because you
guys see you guys see
stuff coming down and you comment oh i
know i hadn't thought about that
oh is that weird that's how i behaved i
didn't know that
why why do you think society is in the
[__] right now because of that
yeah that's because of us yeah it's
because of comedians so so how do
children plug into this
so here's the point so if you have a
community
uh that where children are doing well
the majority of children are going to
school they're getting the health care
they need
everything's fine that portends well
for the future that's a society and a
community
that is trying to
make sure that the next generation has
the
ability to take care of the problems and
the challenges that will certainly be
facing us from climate change
uh to dealing with pandemics and so on
but if you have
on the other hand a community where
children are not doing well
where there's failures in school where
these kids are not getting health care
that is a very bad sign and that's why
i'm saying that children are the
bellwethers
you can measure the success of society
by how well our children
are doing and if they're doing poorly
watch out because
we are not going to be in the same
position 20 years from now we're already
tumbling in terms of
international leadership and inspiration
and it's just going to get a whole lot
worse and i but i think
look i have apologized multiple times
to young people for the mess that we're
leaving them
this is a family podcast so i'm not
going to use the language i used in
front of these
400 young people but i apologize for the
mess that we that we're leaving and
actually it's true you know
when i first started my career was in
1971 and 72
in rural arkansas running a a
government-funded clinic
i was you know i'm a child of the
kennedy and johnson heiress and i
thought
10 or 15 years from 1972
we would have ended child poverty we
would have ended racism we would have uh
ended uh lack of access to health care
and i said in 10 or 15 years this will
all be history here we are
half a century later neil and and paul
and it's like
what the hell did we do or didn't do uh
to leave the country as much as it was
yeah paul's right it's it's just your
fault
it is you know it's my fault you spend
less time
if you spend less time with hey hey
here's my book everybody
and you know
we get it you have a book
you know can i just say something though
like
this goes back to what we're talking
about earlier the problem with this
thing
is the elephant in the room and it's not
even something you want to talk about
it's the politics
i hear all of these goals and the
politics is going to continue to get in
the way
wait wait wait wait however however i'm
i'm
um i'm going to quote my father my late
father who said it's not good enough to
be right
you also have to be effective so if you
know
the politics are going to get in the way
then you navigate that
okay you so it's not like you politics
in the way and you're in a prison
all right we live we still kind of live
in a free society and especially in
modern times
with access to the internet and podcasts
and everything else you are not
we are not powerless um but let me ask
you did your book has
you have other anecdotes about um your
encounters with children
sure so there's another one uh of a um
a kid i saw in a waiting room in the
south bronx and i'm just i was actually
waiting for
my wife and i sat down in the waiting
room with the kids and the families
and i see this little kid a girl playing
with a little
a little toy shark and i'm saying that
she's
and i said uh what what kind of uh
fish is that says it's a shark
and then she went and gave this was this
kid was i don't remember 12.
and she went into this long explanation
about different species of sharks
and it was it's in the south bronx in
the poor zip
urban zip code in america and this kid
was clearly in love with the science
of of uh marine biology and okay so paul
you know what he's really saying here he
said
uh so with those two examples we need
more movies like
jaws and jurassic park that's what
you're saying here
exactly and he just happened to have
writing he just happened to have written
a script for both of those for sequels
that he's sold it's just pimping stuff
that's all he's doing
i didn't even think of that that's good
but you know this kid
had never been to an aquarium in fact
most of the kids that i've talked about
have never been to one of new york's
museums which are the
envy of the world and it's just
incredible how much we are
blockading children from the experiences
and the opportunities
to pursue their lives like like our
children
are able to do and it's a pathetic
indictment really of us so they were
and then then there was a kid who was a
phenomenal graphic artist
and i saw him in a homeless shelter um
his name was raymond and he had this big
old
you know backpack russac whatever it's
called
and i said what's in there he said uh oh
just my artwork
and he started showing me drawing after
drawing he's done
he carries it around with him because if
you're homeless you gotta you gotta
you gotta move around with it right yeah
he's gotta take cause he didn't trust
leaving in any place
and it was unbelievable and this kid was
in a sh i saw him in a shelter in
brooklyn
and he had also never been to an art
museum in new york city
it's it's astounding so
this is the this is the problem and i
was looking at it at a micro level and
then the book goes into well what's the
big picture here
and it's it's unfortunate but i also
would say
there's there's optimism to be had here
neil i think we can fix
it this is not our inevitable fate
well let's take a break and let's find
out what is your recipe for fixing it
before paul just rails on you one more
time
you think you can do it let's take a
quick break and when we come back
more with erwin redliner just telling us
about how we're going to
survive this coveted pandemic and what
our kids
what role they will need to play going
forward on star talk
we're back star talk i got paul
mercurial paul good to have you man
oh great to be here all right and you're
looking healthier than the last time we
had you on
uh you you're rising up out of covert do
you have your taste
buds back yet no i don't i mean i do
some days and sometimes in the middle of
a meal
i'll taste it and then all of a sudden i
can't taste anything for the rest did
you find out oh i thought i ordered
pizza but i'm eating cardboard from
staples okay it's really helping my
budget
[Laughter]
the cardboard is cheap also for some
reason soda right now
coke ginger ale can't can't
drink it it has this horrible taste and
i don't know if there's a chemical in
there or something
yeah okay yeah yeah so so so
uh irwin we've we've been talking about
your book the future of
us and so what you're telling us
is that it has sort of gut-wrenching
stories of children who will never
realize their potential
so do you have any positive i don't mean
to make light of that fact but
generally this is america we like happy
endings to things
so are you doing something is the
country doing something
is the world doing something how are we
not going to lose people
i i think about you uh often neil
because you are the purveyor of the most
effective articulation of the need for
people learning and science and what
that means to us
and we're in a very bad spot right now
and the solution
is not just you continuing to talk but
we've we gotta get people who will
listen
and people who hold the purse strings
and are able to change policies
and this is why to paul's point the
answer unfortunately and unfortunately
for a lot of scientists a lot of public
health experts
who keep thinking if they write one more
paper that somehow
government magic wins and they'll do the
right thing it's just [__]
and what is going to matter is having
the right
recipients of the information that are
controlling our dollars
and our policies that's i mean that's
what it's boiled down to for me
and uh look i think the answer is that
we need
something that i mentioned before that
we're calling like a marshall plan for
children which is
the marshall plan referring as you
pointed out to the uh
the incredible investment we made in
europe to have it recover after world
war ii
we need a similar investment a moonshot
that will make us adhere to a national
vision for what we can do
and an investment to make sure that no
child goes to an
inadequate school every child has health
care they need
and families are helped to rise out of
poverty well you know i hadn't heard
that phrase in so many decades a
national vision
wow yeah yeah it's only just about me
and you and it's not about us
yeah well now the word us is in your
title of your book
the future of us so paul let's let's go
let's go to
i think you have some questions that you
got from instagram
on instagram we have something from uh
manavaret11
how will the pandemic affect children
whose analytic brain is still developing
ooh interesting yeah so so does the code
get in the brain
or is it just disrupting the system that
educates you and so now there's a gap in
when you could have
learned but you can't right now it's
actually both neo
because we know that uh there can be
neurological symptoms uh
from people that had covert there was
just a report out that children
uh are we're increasingly uh
seeing the uh problems of uh the effect
on the neurological system and brain
function in children
still very small numbers but something
for us to
worry about unfortunately and uh that's
what we're dealing with but also
well just to generalize that notion just
to generalize it
so what we're saying here is if you have
a fully
formed brain yeah it's more it's it's
more
uh resistant to assaults on it whatever
those assaults might be
relative to one that is still taking
shape this is a very important point and
this is why the focus should be on
children
because if you experience trauma and if
you get coveted or you
you are in a you know refugee camp and
you're for years you're suffering and
in in agony you will once the situation
the adversities leave
you are feeling better and you are
better for children
who are especially younger children
whose brain is in active development
mode
they are affected by all sorts of trauma
and all sorts of absence of the
appropriate stimulation of the brain
which is why it's a problem if they are
interrupted in their educational
uh trajectory so yeah if the children
if it's there's a timeliness here
uh with doing what children need versus
what adults need and uh
that's has to do with the biology of
brain development and it's really
important you know exactly as you point
out all right cool all right paul
next uh next one by the way
is there any chances covid and
regarding kids brains anything to kind
of keep them from asking why
a millionaire i'm not saying i'm a fan
of it
why do you ask
you're smarter than i am you're funnier
than i am okay numbers here we go next
neither is true but okay
um what kind of mental effects is being
in quarantine having on people
especially
teenagers yeah yeah so it depends
because some families and children do
okay
and some don't so what's the difference
so
the families are able to become more
resilient
to the traumas and weirdness associated
with quarantine and
and all the other regulations and rules
that we have now in a coveted world
is that you know for children we set up
a schedule we have uh
we create play times we're eating as
together as a family
we talk through things that are
bothering us and we entertain ourselves
the best we can
i'm telling you you know comedians just
to make a point here
paul are really important because of not
only the insights
that come from good comedy if they're
really important
but they also aren't distracting from
focusing on the
downside the doom side of what we're
dealing we're going to be dealing with
covet 19 for another couple years
so we got to settle in we got to figure
out ways to
keep ourselves uh intact mentally and
psychologically
and it's really important it's about
building adaptability
adaptability and uh and resilience
in young people and it's doable and this
is one of the things i talk about in the
book
uh interesting because this notion about
comedy i'm a big fan of comedy
and i know you are okay and so and i
attempt it every now and then not on the
stage but i'll
i'll speckle what i'm doing with
some attempt to try to be funny so i i
tweeted recently
the beginning of a of a coronavirus joke
but not having the end of it i invited
people to give me their best ending
and i just simply said a coronavirus
walks into a bar that's all i said i
said
give me some help here i need a punch
line i i don't have a punch line
and so 2 000
entries if you want to call it that came
came by but anyhow
there were a few not many maybe three or
four people
who said you are making light of a
pandemic where 200 000 people have died
i expect more serious communication from
you and
so irwin your point that you have to
see the humor in the tragedy otherwise
you've got no
lifeline i mean i don't want to i don't
want to second judge how those people
actually felt about it
but you seem to be saying that i was
okay
you're you're endorsing the fact that i
at least attempted this exercise
so i was speaking with nicole wallace
and a new york times reporter named nick
confissary
on msnbc a couple of weeks ago camera
i think we mentioned this but and i'm
talking about something very serious
about a big
uptick in kovid and i see nicole wallace
starting to smile and nick come stories
laughing
and i don't and i realized i turned my
head
and my four-year-old grandson my
youngest grandson has
made a cameo appearance and has appeared
on either side of me jumping up and down
and listen
that clip got over six hundred thousand
views
and i was inundated with texts and not
text
with uh tweets from people saying they
loved it they laughed it was the first
big laugh they've had in
you know months it was an incredibly
positive
uniformly positive response and it
points out to me what you just said
we need a break we need a break
um and you know this is the kind of you
know humor that people don't get that
you know like
in the uh operating rooms and whatever
amongst docs you know
you you are taking a break from the
sorrow and the tragedy and that's
human and i'm i'm fine with it i don't
mock anything about the seriousness and
i'm a major attacker of trump and all
that but
you know my god we're all feeling
incredible stress
incredible you know if you don't have
the comedy to make a point
then like you said it just becomes this
sort of more morose
uh you know it's yeah it's not working
you know so paul i think we got time for
like one or two more questions okay if
we can answer them efficiently
in a few more sorry no no i just know i
was
we love your stories no i was not
dissing on you
no um uh this is from uh
adam gulotta how do we become more
educated as
uh citizens on covet 19
people think it's fake yeah so so let me
let me reshape that erwin
the the source of education to learn
what is not fake is
out there so there's a wanton
disregard for what is true by a subset
of the people
what do you do with them it's not a
matter of just oh here's what the truth
is
oh i never knew that and then everyone
holds hands right so let me just
harken back to the anti-vaxx movement
that existed
you know for decades long before kovac
came
did you ever speak to somebody who was
opposed to vaccines
it's you you cannot there's i
i don't know at least what to tell
people about the truth
that co that uh the mumps measles rebel
vaccine
that it does not cause autism it's been
the best
as as they say you can't use reason to
argue someone out of a point that they
didn't use reason to get into right
these are the same people who
electrocute themselves on a regular
basis you're not going to be able to
convince them when these people said to
me it's fake in florida it's a hoax
i looked in their eyes they weren't they
believed it in their soul
well paul that was florida we know
there's a headline there was a headline
i have this headline
it it was florida sheriff urges
residents not to shoot their guns into
the hurricane
because this was a this
was a so florida we're not something
florida's another outlier yeah
yeah so so do you have anything up your
sleeve iron
for folks that you can't otherwise
convince
yeah it's very very difficult and i this
in a certain way is your core business
um you know neil yeah it is of trying to
help people understand how important
knowledge and truth
is and i don't you know i'm not sure
what the ticket is to to make this
happen
right now if anything softens people
it's how things affect their children
and children and there's studies that
save the children did a study and
regarding the effects of
of what's going on and it's you know 83
percent of the kids reported
negative feelings and their violence was
a violence uptick in the home
and and so forth dropping out domestic
violence yeah
sure so that those facts are facts and
when you put that in front of people
even who are skeptical is is maybe
should there be a greater emphasis on
studies like that and and what
and the information that they just you
can reach them emotionally then
rather than yeah yeah sure those studies
are good but i think
neil might confirm this information does
not necessarily convince someone
who has deep ideological
religious whatever it is there's there's
no competition
science and facts unfortunately turn out
to be
not a strong competitor and i know
you know the two people that i you know
well
you neil and uh are late pal uh
carl says yeah spent
lives and careers on trying to get
people to understand the beauty and the
importance
of learning through the
scientific process or whatever you want
to call it
uh but really really being curious about
how the world works and
that curiosity plays out as we learn
more and we learn more through science
and evidence and all that
so we're going to have to leave it at
that
that's at least a mildly uh uplifting
thought relative to everything else that
came out of your mouth in the last
[Laughter]
this is kind of embarrassing in a way
but yeah i take it
you'll take that you take it you take it
paul keep getting better thank you
and put down that cardboard it's not a
pepperoni pizza
and i always say this and i want to say
it again if i had neil
as my science teacher i would be a
scientist today
erwin redliner's book the future of us
um
an exploration of how children will
inherit in earth
and what kind of earth do we want to
hand over to them
and so erwin always good to see you on
star talk likewise
neil degrasse tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist as always
bidding you
to keep looking up